hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where today i wasn't actually
planning to make any videos for the
entire week
um but a lot of my policy with youtube
is generally
if i haven't seen anyone else say
something or if i don't feel like
an aspect of something is being covered
then i will do my best to talk about it
um generally if things have already been
spoken about i don't feel the need to
add my voice to the choir
um and with things that people
aren't talking about it generally means
people are going to be pretty mad so i
know that this video is likely to make
people mad
definitely the headline for anyone who's
not reading or not watching the video
and just went straight off the headline
will probably piss some people off
but this is a perspective that i felt
was valuable to
uh share especially after reaching out
to 12
different developers obviously i could
have done a much larger pool than that
but
that was the people that i quickly had
access to to ask about this
both being current activision blizzard
and past activision blizzard employees
and every single one of them agreed with
me so
i also have sources to share okay let's
anyway
so for anyone who missed the news
somehow
activision blizzard uh is currently
under investigation there was a lawsuit
filed by california state regarding
uh sexual harassment and sexual
discrimination
at the workplace um there's been a lot
of discussion of different facets of
this
and there was a walkout last wednesday i
believe
where employees uh effectively protested
they also had a blackout that went in
tandem with that where they were
encouraging people to not log on to
blizzard games for a certain period of
time it was just on one day i think for
a few hours
and they listed a bunch of
causes that they would like people to
donate to and i will share the links to
those in the description below
one thing that i have only seen
the opposite suggestion for but again i
don't feel like i see the public talking
about
uh is the discussion of boycotting
activision blizzard and not buying any
of their games
the one video that i previously made
about the the situation
um i said i don't think you should
boycott i just made one very small
comment about that i didn't elaborate on
it
and even that did get some pushback um i
also tweeted about it and ended up
deleting it because i didn't
want to argue it uh but
generally the public um i can't say
generally there are just some people i
don't know what percentage
who are suggesting that you should
boycott activision blizzard games
because of the working conditions that
people have been dealing with at
activision blizzard
i don't think this is a good
idea first um you know there have been a
lot of
different people who work at the studio
who have tweeted about not wanting you
to do this
and there are a lot of layers to this
and a lot of reasons why but i'm just
going to show you
uh one thread here from tammy siegmund
who
is a senior producer at blizzard
she goes by at copy on twitter let me
just drag this over here
okay gotta cover my own face that's fine
who needs to see that um okay so this
tweet is from july 26th
it says on one hand i completely
understand why people would want to
spend their money elsewhere rather than
support a company that doesn't align
with their morals
on the other hand it's a really bad
feeling for those of us women who still
work and fight daily at said company
when people don't spend money on our
games it affects my profit sharing and
what my bonus percentages
the impact of this lawsuit might mean
that in march when my newborn goes to
full-time child care and my maternity
leave ends
i might not get the bonus i need to pay
for that child care
anyway not telling anyone how to spend
your money just hoping that maybe the
folks to change their phrasing from
out of support for the women at blizzard
to something else because as a pregnant
woman at blizz it would not feel
supportive to lose my income
it feels a bit different than say
avoiding shopping at hobby lobby or
eating at chick-fil-a because most of us
who signed up to join blizzard had no
idea it would be like this since it's so
misaligned with the company values we
project
i know i personally thought we'd be a
lot more removed from activision
and i also didn't know that our parent
company would be hiring so many
right-wing senior executives but here we
are and of course the disclaimer my
tweets do not
represent my employer and their views
and recent public statements do not
represent me what i believe
so there are several tweets that i like
this um and this one's just a good
example because i feel like she's
speaking about something that
affects her very personally um or
financially
which is effectively if you
boycott activision blizzard games even
with the thought process of oh but if
there's no money change then
they won't change anything a lawsuit's
going to cost them a lot of money and
their stocks have dropped
um and i still understand the validity
of that argument
anyway um while thinking that
it probably won't make a difference and
they will find other ways to make money
but i still understand the validity of
it
the truth is though that it negatively
impacts developers um it can lead to
layoffs as well of course
uh but you know as she said there
firsthand it can
impact bonuses it can stop them from
earning money and it also and this is
the thing that i've had a lot of
conversations with people in the
industry about i spoke to people at
naughty dog about this
um quite extensively when people were
saying to boycott the last of his part
two
due to crunch in the studio when you
work at one of these companies
and there's any kind of culture issue or
the environment sucks
the people who say just quit are clearly
not understanding that you work there
because you actually love your job
you love what you do for a living you
work hard
and the reward for working hard is
sharing what you do with the world and
having players see what you do
so i can speak to this first hand i
worked at um
ign when there was a walkout for sexual
harassment
um and
some of the audience responses saying
i'm never going to read ign again
just felt like being kicked while we
were already down
because even if you boycott the site
what that actually does is just reduce
the thing that i
enjoyed about working there so the thing
that i liked about working there was
getting to write about
things that i liked working really hard
on those features getting them out on
time making sure people saw the reviews
that was why you stay even when a
company has
tremendous shortcomings and i guess it
feels gross to call these shortcomings
but
i know that that's the case for a lot of
these people they work at a bad place
but they do something that they
absolutely love
and when the audience was saying i'm
just not going to read ign again i was
like i feel like you're just punishing
me and you're taking away the thing that
i loved about this place that had
downsides
rather than actually punishing corporate
because it's
the one thing about it that drives you
right so
for a lot of developers again i've
spoken to so many about this and and i
don't want to speak on behalf of every
dev because i'm sure there's someone out
there who feels differently i've just
not met the person who said anything
contrary to this but i'm sure they exist
and i don't want to invalidate their
perspective i just wanted to share
mine and the sentiment that i've seen
echoed by a lot of developers
is yeah by not playing the thing that
they worked really hard on the the
reason that they work there the products
that they're very passionate about
making
you are almost taking away the thing
that made them stay through all of the
garbage
and it's well intentioned and i get that
and i really do understand the logic of
oh but will they
change if it doesn't hit their wallets
but i don't
think enough people would necessarily do
it to have that impact anyway but
even if it did their changes would more
likely be
that they would figure out ways to
monetize their games more extensively
more microtransactions um or layoffs
rather than
changing the culture because that is
human
beings personalities changing and public
pressure
tweeting demanding for for action um i
think does
help um i think it's hollow if you don't
try to do anything more than that
especially if you work in the games
industry that that kind of thing drives
me not seeing people who actually do
work in development
tweet but in the offices where they see
these problems happening don't do
anything
but i do think public pressure to be
like hey activision
this sucks can have an impact that pr
team is going to see that their stocks
did drop and that is super important it
was i think dropped by 20
that has to make a change that's that's
probably more important than sales in
the grand scheme of things so i do want
to encourage people to still speak their
minds but
boycotting the games and tweeting about
how you should all boycott the games and
how you shouldn't play ubisoft games and
shouldn't even talk about them
is just like i've spoken to people at
ubisoft about this too
for the good people trying to do good
work in a shitty environment
you are also just taking away that that
thing that they have
that keeps them going that they're proud
of that they find fulfilling that's a
positive in all of the negative
um and i know
again i'm sure this will make people mad
but it is it is very strongly the way
that i feel especially as someone who
again did go through a boycott
if i work for a company that did
something shitty and as a result of it
you
stopped watching any of the work that
i've done
or any of the work that any of my
colleagues had done that just feels like
i'm getting slapped because the
company's bad
and i i know a lot of other people feel
this way um again don't want to speak
for everyone
so then it brings us to the point of
like well what can the public
do what options do they actually
have i have already spoken obviously
about
i do think that there's uh if there are
enough people doing it putting pressure
on activision publicly
saying things is helpful um i do think
tweeting your opinion is helpful i do
think donating to the charities that
they've asked for is helpful tweeting
support to the devs who are going
through a difficult time is helpful
um and of course i'm not going to tell
you to not play these games if you don't
feel comfortable that's a separate thing
like you're absolutely allowed to not
play the games i'm not telling you
playing them is directly being
supportive it's more that saying that
you're never going to play any of
the things these people worked on at
this place ever again is just not
supportive kind of like um what the
tweet said here i feel like she phrased
it
quite well at the top
is uh i completely understand why people
would want to spend their money
elsewhere rather than support a company
that doesn't align with their morals
but it is a really bad feeling for us
who still work and fight daily at said
company i completely agree with that so
i get that there are layers to it
um and that you know it's just the
phrasing of i'm boycotting to support
the women who work there i don't think
is the right way to speak about that
because you are not supporting the women
who work there by doing that at all
you are probably hurting them um so for
what the public can
do honestly i've thought about this a
lot
my video where i first spoke about
harassment in activision blizzard
was directed at telling
people everywhere to
combat sexual harassment and sexual
assault if you see something bad
happening
and i even mean this in terms of
bullying not just harassment and
certainly not just directed at women um
if you see someone being mistreated say
something and i do think this is
something that should span
every industry not just the games
industry but it's real world change that
affects culture and that can go into the
tech industry into the games industry
even if you don't work there
you know if if you're in high school and
you see people making fun of
someone because they are assaulted which
is a thing that happens
um because that happened to me then
say something please that's that's the
thing that i would first ask people to
do is in the real world
actually say something when it comes to
the games industry specifically i do
think speaking up about it
does something my approach often is to
if i'm going to talk about
a um an activist or blizzard title i
will give a disclaimer i'll be like want
to address that
this company has issues so nobody
doesn't know that but i'm not going to
stop playing their games
or talking about their games if i really
like them um
when the uh hearthstone thing happened
with blitzchang i did decline to cover
anything
at um uh blizzcon that year that was
what i opted to do was just not talk
about any of their trailers or anything
like that but it didn't mean it was
going to be a hard and fast rule forever
you know
um otherwise though if you really
genuinely want to have an impact on the
games industry
a big one a significant one it's not
just don't buy their games i would say
and obviously this requires you to have
money more so than just you know the 60
that one game costs
buy stocks when a company does something
that you like sell them
when they do something that you don't
like obviously
this is not something that you can
guarantee will be profitable for you and
that's where i feel like most people
would just lose
on this i think about it a lot and like
if we could just get all of these gamers
who care about this stuff to buy stocks
when they do something positive and sell
all their stocks when they do something
negative
maybe that would do something but then
my head goes i bet you
90 of those people because it stocks the
minute that they
are in that market will their brains
will flip and they will go but money
they will change the morals will
disappear because that's how people
operate they'll they'll go away and i'll
be like but the tracking i need to sell
here so i can earn more money and they
won't be thinking about it from the
perspective of like betterment of the
industry but
i do feel like that would work if you
have a lot of money
and you happen to be watching this and
you want to have an impact on the games
industry
buy stocks when companies do something
that you really like
and sell them when they do something
that you really dislike
i'm not equipped to give you financial
advice and that is not financial advice
it's almost moral advice
but um that's the thing that i think
would help much more than
boycotting games because again if it
does work it hurts the devs
it cuts into their bonuses it ruins the
thing that they
love um and more realistically it
probably
won't work because not enough people
will do it uh to make an impact on a
company the size of activision blizzard
because i always have to remind people
the games industry or the game's
community is so big the amount of people
who play video games
who don't even know what activision
blizzard is is enormous
it's in the millions i don't think
enough people would boycott call of duty
for it to actually have an impact on
call of duty um
in any case um
and i still don't think it would change
anything i still think that the result
would just be okay we need to figure out
better ways to monetize i don't think
they'd be like we should get rid of
sexism because it's not something that
they can even prove so
i don't know this is unedited because
videos take me like eight hours to
upload so i'm just trying to do it
hopefully it's not too rambly but um i
just wanted to share this
perspective because like i said it's not
one that i've seen people cover
i've seen a lot of hostility when i have
seen the devs tweet it so i just wanted
to
share where it's coming from uh
reiterate that i have seen a lot of
devs and spoken to a lot of people who
feel this way including
at ubisoft and at naughty dog um and
that i understand
the difficult situation that the public
is in where you feel helpless for
something that you don't condone
i'm not going to tell you please keep
playing their games please keep buying
their games i'm definitely not going to
do that especially
if you don't agree with them but um
i don't think boycotts are
helpful and i think for every developer
who is
reading the tweet saying [ __ ] boycott
it just deflates them and bums them out
um
i don't know hopefully people don't get
too mad about this it just felt like
something that i needed
to say so yeah friendly reminder
something i always try to do maybe this
is too preachy
is for every negative tweet write a
positive one
for every tweet where you're saying [ __ ]
activision [ __ ] blizzard
and boycotting all of their games you
could also write a
full support to the dev team you know it
it helps it makes a difference to those
people's
just overall the input that they're
getting if you can increase the
positivity even a little bit
you can't pretend that that doesn't make
a difference in times like this so
yeah that's it today um i will see you
guys next time